je viens de recevoir deux colis d'Apple
pas un colis d'Apple deux colis d'Apple
regardez je pense que on va commencer
par celui-là on a d'un côté le nouvel
iPhone nouvelle iPhone qui est juste là
c'est l'iPhone 14 pro max on va
commencer par le plus grand le plus haut
de gamme regardez on a la petite coque
de l'iPhone 14 pro max on a la F14 pro
max et on a le leader white ok donc ça
c'est ce qu'on regarde aujourd'hui c'est
le programme de la vidéo et ça on en
parle dans deux trois jours c'est la
nouvelle Apple watch ça c'est la série 8
alors la série 8 je vais la mettre au
poignet je vous en parle un peu plus
tard donc laissez-moi un peu de temps
mais tout de suite on va se concentrer
sur ce nouvel iPhone alors moi en fait
je vous explique tout de suite ce qu'on
va faire on va pas aller faire un
unboxing qui va durer des heures on va
juste l'ouvrir je vais le configurer
très rapidement et surtout on va aller
faire les premières photos et première
vidéo je veux très très rapidement voir
si le capteur 48 mégapixels il a un réel
intérêt ou pas regardé c'est joli c'est
très sympa comme ça et j'aime beaucoup
alors ça c'est vraiment les couleurs
violettes c'est un nouveau violet j'ai
bouffé la référence mais qui est
vraiment superbe hop là bon on connaît
les iPhone après on sait qu'on a plus de
blocs de charge à l'intérieur c'est pas
nouveau qui est toujours en Lightning
après c'est un iPhone alors après je me
pose une autre question si regardez on
va comparer par rapport à mon iphone 13
Max qui est juste là vous voyez c'est
vraiment la même chose il est joli
violet mais j'aime bien les protéger si
je vais mettre mes coques monsieur gros
ici faites voir parce que c'est vraiment
la même chose ou pas ah ouais ils ont
fait un petit changement alors c'est
très très très discret hein si vous
regardez voyez là cette partie là ils
l'ont descendu en diagonale par rapport
à l'autre et ça je le vois avec la coque
donc il y a vraiment une toute petite
différence mais elle a une nu je me
rends pas compte c'est assez dingue
regardez je la remets sur l'iPhone 13
pro max donc là là je fais bien le tour
là de tous les côtés donc là ça marche
et sur l'iPhone 14 pro max ils ont
légèrement bougé je pense que c'est à
cause des coques en fait c'est pour
revendre des nouvelles coques qui font
ça je vois pas sinon l'intérêt de garder
un dos vous voyez là donc là je l'ai
bien là mais là après je l'ai pas donc
ils ont légèrement bougé pour que vous
veniez acheter les coques et ça c'est
malin parce que si on le regarde comme
ça sinon c'est exactement la même chose
ouais ils sont quand même hyper mal hein
chez Apple le bloc photo peut-être un
peu plus grand ici par rapport à la mais
c'est vraiment du gros gros point de
détail on se rend pas énormément compte
vous voyez il est un peu plus large un
peu plus grand sur téléphone 14 pro max
versus l'iPhone 13 pro max ce qui
explique effectivement qu'il faut des
coques ici en fait maintenant que je le
regarde je m'en rend mieux compte
regarder par rapport à la pomme par
rapport à l'endroit où on arrive le bloc
photo est plus grand car comme vous avez
un nouveau capteur de 48 mégapixels ça
vient s'expliquer là bon ok allez je le
configure on y va générique et on va
aller se balader on va regarder à faire
les premières photos on se fait le
premier retour et d'ici quelques jours
on fera le test complet de l'iPhone 14
pro max donc venez vous abonner c'est
pas déjà fait on va également spy la
nouvelle watch qui est juste là la Watch
série 8 on se parlera également de
l'iPhone 14 plus qui peut-être l'iPhone
le plus intéressant cette année et on se
parlera probablement aussi de la Watch
ultra donc ça c'est bien idrpods voilà
on n'arrête pas bref on y va
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec rhinoshield
parce que vous le savez c'est très
important de venir protéger son
smartphone et de lui mettre une coque de
protection je vous le dis tout de suite
exceptionnellement pour la sortie des
iPhone 14 à partir de maintenant le
lancement de la vidéo vous avez -15% de
remise pendant 48 heures 48 heures
uniquement je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description allez jeter un œil
moins 15% ça se refuse pas et tout ça
avec le code gros 22 GRR 22 sherine
aussi vous avez plein de produits pour
venir à protéger vos iPhone donc ça
c'est vachement bien et avoir des
glaires des Solutis il y en a vachement
et vous avez également plein de
collaborations avec différentes marques
mais surtout est-ce qu'il vachement
intéressantes ça y est enfin les coques
rhinoshield sont compatibles maxaf à
partir de l'iPhone 12 13 14 sauf les
mini vous êtes donc pour venir protéger
et personnaliser vos iPhone avec
différents produits vous avez la clear
case qui est très jolie transparente
vous voyez le dos de votre iPhone super
expérience alors on laisse soit comme ça
tout transparent soit on peut venir
totalement le personnaliser si on le
souhaite vous avez également le mode et
NX qu'on peut également venir totalement
personnaliser la solitude qui est une
coque complète avec des boutons
interchangeables si vous le souhaitez et
vous avez également le grip Max qui est
une poignée pour tenir solidement votre
iPhone c'est produire rhinoshield sont
totalement personnalisables dans
différents univers alors vous allez bien
avoir du Summer du Rainbow des animaux
si et ça vous en avez des tonnes de tous
les côtés mais ils ont également des
collaborations que ce soit One Piece
Snoopy Star Wars Lord of the Rings
Dragon Ball Z Naruto Marvel j'en passe
des meilleurs il y en a énormément
vraiment pour tout le monde du League of
Legends Game of Thrones la NBA Disney
Princesse le PSG Hello Kitty in friends
my hero academia Rick et Morty le musée
Van Gogh Snoopy il y en a tellement que
je vous laisse venir jeter un œil
directement via le lien en bas dans la
description pour trouver le produit qui
vous fera plaisir vous pouvez même
imprimer vos photos et faire graver vos
initiales comme ça en terme de
personnalisation on est au top une fois
de plus profiter de - 15 % pendant 48
heures et uniquement 48 heures pensez
vraiment à venir protéger votre iPhone
pour éviter les déconvenus parce que si
votre iPhone tombe normalement il est
solide ça devrait bien se passer mais on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer allez
jeter un coup d'oeil vient le lien en
bas moi 15% le code c'est gros 22 et
merci à rhinoshield d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo
[Musique]
l'objectif normal aujourd'hui c'est fou
je pense que ça devrait j'espère le
corriger pour vous et la ça qui nous
intéresse quand on vient filmer
directement à l'arrière mais là on filme
sur le capteur de 48 mégapixels donc ça
c'est vraiment la grosse nouveauté cette
année ce capteur de 48 mégapixels vous
voyez c'est le premier test on regardera
ça plus en détail plus tard donc là je
suis sur le capteur principal et on
passe sur l'ultra grand-angle qui en 12
mégapixels voilà ça c'est l'ultra
grand-angle bon on connaissait déjà mais
le truc qui est nouveau cette année
c'est qu'on va pouvoir faire un X 2 ou 1
x 3 donc regardez là hop là je passe en
fois là le X 2 en fait ça c'est un X 2
on vient grimper dans le capteur de 48
mégapixels donc on est toujours sur le
48 mégapixels on va faire en fois dedans
donc en fait là tu t'en trouves en 24
mégapixels et après je fais x 3 et là je
change carrément d'objectif là je me
trouve effectivement sur un téléobjectif
x 3 optique donc en fait j'ai un X 2 qui
est un X 2 numérique et qui vient
grimper dans un 14 48 mégapixels et j'ai
un X 3 optique c'est un peu un peu
compliqué cette année on peut augmenter
et en vidéo jusqu'à 1 x 9 voilà bon faut
de faire non mais l'idée du X3 comme ça
et du X 2 je trouve ça assez malin et
sur la partie photo c'est la même chose
regardez ultra grand-angle le X 2 c'est
14 48 mégapixels donc on va préserver
les détails donc ça c'est pas mal et le
X 3 alors on va regarder parce que il se
peut que là lorsqu'on fait une photo
avec le foin vous êtes réellement en
fait sur un 40 Méga Pixel mais ça vous
semble une photo avec 4 pixel en un donc
il faut que 12 mégapixels mais si vous
passez sur le X 2 comme ça on va être
sur un 24 mégapixels alors est-ce que ça
va quand même leur descendre avec du 2
pixels en main pour rater plus de
lumière j'en sais rien on va regarder il
faudra laisser quelques temps pour qu'on
se rendrait mon compte et ensuite vous
avez x 3 là par contre c'est vraiment de
quel objectif mais l'idée d'avoir voyez
ces quatre combinaisons différentes
comme ça présente sur votre écran je
trouve ça assez marrant alors une des
nouveautés cette année c'est d'avoir le
mode cinématique en 4K en images
regardez vous le voyez en os là 4K Full
HD 4K 30 4K 24 alors le mode cinématique
regardez ça vous reconnaît vous allez
pouvoir venir faire le focus verrouillé
sur d'autres gens à côté c'est
exactement la même chose qu'on avait
raté l'année dernière j'étais calme ça
reste là il faut que c'est fait là c'est
exactement le même principe sauf que là
vous allez monter la résolution vous
passez en 4K 30 ça c'est pas mal et là
vous réglez aussi votre ouverture
4 je monte jusqu'à F13 et descends
jusqu'à 2 alors j'ai le mode cinématique
sur ma caméra de selfie mais la regarder
de cette bazar voilà là je suis à 11
est-ce que je peux choisir les gens
derrière vous voyez je vais sur eux moi
je suis complètement flou je rappuie sur
moi dans voilà net et j'ai plusieurs
petits points envoyés à plat je fais
cette dame là et là moi comme ça c'est
marrant et même en caméra de selfie là
je suis en 4 ans de vous voyez
là moi
je suis folle on est sur moi
caméra de selfie donc là on va à même
sur la pub Gucci rôle vous voyez ça leur
connait je fais ça je reviens là ça
revient sur moi je regarde la base que
ça repère les gens c'est un peu petit
vraiment bluffant parce que vous voyez
on augmente significativement la qualité
là quand je filme il y a pas de stade ça
bouge mais peut-être qu'il y aura une
correction après on regarde ça ensemble
regardez elles sont ma caméra de selfie
ça bouge énormément je sais pas si vous
en rendez compte ça bouge et pour autant
lorsque je regarde après les rush
directement donc là je me regarde voyez
là je vois que ça tremble quand même du
feu de Dieu et pour autant sur les
roches c'est assez Store c'est pas
complètement parfait mais c'est quand
même un peu stable donc ça c'est quand
même assez bluffant mais parce que c'est
sur la caméra de selfie caméra arrière à
mon avis ça a beaucoup mieux à rien donc
toujours là en mode cinématique c'est un
peu mieux stabilisé mais c'est pas
parfait donc là il a quand même un peu
de mal du point de vue logiciel donc ça
c'est le mode cinématique mais si
j'enlève le mode cinématique maintenant
ça devrait être mieux donc là je suis
sur le mode standard alors je crois que
ça bouge toujours un peu lorsque je
regarde après normalement ça bouge pas
et si on veut vraiment pas que ça bouge
on lui a carrément le mode action pour
activer le mode action cam je viens
juste là ici là et là par contre je suis
en 2,8k 60 je peux pas aller en 4K ça
c'est le plus haut que je puisse et là
par contre là je vais avoir la meilleure
stabilisation alors j'ai testé j'ai fait
pas mal de choses c'est vrai que ça
c'est bluffant ça bouge pas mal il y a
vraiment une stabilisation de base déjà
mais surtout au niveau logiciel il faut
un boulot qui est dingue et qui est
vachement efficace voir ce mode d'action
là si c'est bien comme ça
compte si ça va être bien ou pas bien on
va regarder ça c'est pas mal en fait ça
pour le mode action ce qu'il faut
vraiment que je fasse c'est que j'essaye
de le faire comme si je faisais une
vidéo avec une GoPro même si on n'est
pas une et à mon avis c'est vrai pas mal
il y a un truc qui me perturbe vachement
là sur ce nouvel iPhone c'est le always
je me dis [ __ ] mais j'arrive pas à mon
iPhone en fait je clique il s'éteint
donc là attendez donc là il est éteint
regardez si vous voyez la lune devient
un peu plus petite et un peu plus foncé
et ça me fait très bizarre en fait de
pas avoir un écran noir mais bon je
pense que j'aime m'habituer rapidement
enfin j'espère
on se regarde rapidement quelques photos
qui ont été faites cet iPhone pour voir
un peu le rendu il va falloir un peu de
temps pour vraiment aller chercher plus
loin et voir vraiment les différences
entre d'un côté l'iPhone 13 pro max et
de l'autre côté l'iPhone 14 pro max pour
voir si vraiment il y a un intérêt que
le 48 mégapixels alors après il y a
toute la photographie computationnelle
derrière et l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on va retrouver qui a bien optimisé
ça va être difficile de se rendre compte
si ça vient que du capteur ou c'est ça
vient de tout le traitement logiciel je
pense que en réalité c'est un espèce de
mix des deux bon là écoutez c'est c'est
propre c'est jaune après bon pour le
place des Vosges c'est du sable on est
sur un iPhone c'est pas surprenant c'est
très très chaud ce qui est intéressant
une fois de plus c'est de voir ce X1 x 2
x 3 je trouve x 15 ce que je vois là me
paraît propre bon jusqu'au x 15 on
arrive à sortir des choses qui sont
quand même pas dégueu hein très
honnêtement même si c'est pas ouf ouf
faudrait vraiment qu'il y ait enfin un
périscope qui arrive ici sur un iPhone
pour avoir un truc qui soit vraiment top
peut-être qu'on verra arriver à Apple
dans quatre ans ok on a un periscope
it's a révolution ça manque ça manque
vraiment surtout la photo alors après
vous me direz on va pas forcément
chercher du x 15 x 20 mais c'est vrai
que voyez quand on veut venir pousser un
peu plus loin on a tout de suite une la
totalité qui est maximisée ça c'est
dommage qu'on ne l'est pas ici bon ok
c'est un choix regarde tout le détail
moi ça qui m'intéresse au niveau des
arbres bon bah là c'est pas fou fou j'ai
vraiment falloir venir creuser un peu la
question sur différentes scènes pour se
rendre compte c'est pas mal mais je suis
pas sur le cul comme on dit donc bon
après la météo est pas dingue il va
falloir venir chercher un peu des choses
il y a une cohérence colorimétrique ça
c'est plutôt bien là c'est l'ultra
grand-angle ça me déforme le panneau à
gauche hop là en fait grand-angle et on
se rapproche fois 2 fois 3 là c'est
pareil c'est le grand angle on passe
ensuite en ultra grand angle j'aime bien
cette profondeur ça c'est le X 2 c'est
le X 3 et là j'ai posé jusqu'au x 15 bon
voilà histoire de se marrer c'est pas
mal hein c'est pas mal c'est pas mal il
faut vraiment venir le bosser le
chercher regardez là-haut là il y a un
truc c'est un peu cramé là ici au niveau
de l'arbre sur l'ultra grand angle je
vais venir chercher différentes scènes
on regardera ça vraiment lors du test
sur un premier jeu c'est pas mal c'est
correct la caméra de selfie fait le taf
voilà après je vous dis une fois de plus
la lumière aujourd'hui c'est pas un truc
de fou moi un truc qui m'intéresse et
qui me surprend c'est vraiment ce always
on display regardez là j'éteins il y a
plus rien hop je l'allume ça c'est c'est
marrant ça coule en fait c'est tout con
c'est un truc qu'on connaît déjà le
besoin de display mais le voir arriver
sur un iPhone c'est un peu un peu un peu
différent pas donc ça j'aime bien ton
truc qui m'intéresse ici c'est dynamic
Island alors faites voir lorsque je suis
là vous voyez je vais avoir ce truc là
alors bon je pense que lorsque je viens
filmer bon bah forcément ça disparaît
complètement faut apprendre à bien le
découvrir je vais faire aussi un tour un
peu complet et je vous ferai une petite
vidéo alors peut-être sur Youtube shorts
je sais pas faut que je réfléchisse sur
Tik Tok et qu'on paye d'ailleurs si vous
n'êtes pas abonné vous abonner je ferais
peut-être une petite vidéo avec toutes
les différentes facettes de dynamicarion
que j'aurais identifié bon laissez-moi
encore quelques jours pour vraiment me
familiariser avec cet iPhone je connais
le format je connais l'iPhone je le
connais même plutôt très bien mais il y
a quelques petites nouveautés qui pour
le coup sont vraiment intéressantes ici
sur le modèle Pro qu'on a un peu moins
sur le modèle normal on va se faire un
retour complet d'ici quelques jours et
puis n'oubliez pas on parlera également
de la Watch série 8 d'ici quelques jours
et de tous les autres produits de plein
de produits également il y a pas qu'à
une fois il y en a plein d'autres et ça
c'est cool donc prenez soin de vous on
se retrouve très bientôt pour continuer
à parler tech et si d'ici là vous avez
des questions suggestion interrogation
ou des choses en particulier que si je
regarde sur ce nouvel iPhone vous me le
dites en bas dans les commentaires on se
retrouve très vite je vous embrasse pour
les soin de vous des bisous Ciao
[Musique]